I do want the institutions back up and
running and we're obviously talking to
all the political parties here and I
think there is a genuine desire to get
there it will be for the parties here in
Northern Ireland the role of both
governments is to provide the support
and the stability and the conditions to
allow that to happen I do think that in
that essential role which is the honest
broker role that was there when the Good
Friday agreement was signed it's been
there ever since and that's been missing
in the last few years
because the government has not played
that honest broker role in the way that
I think they should have done now
obviously the protocol is a step in the
right direction we supported it and
voted for it and I hope that that window
of opportunity to get the institutions
back up is there but it will be a matter
for the parties here in Northern Ireland
the role of the UK government is to be
that honest broker